[Musique]
le roi Charles III est attendu demain au
château de Versailles et cinq jours
après le 25 septembre vont débuter des
aménagements temporaires pour les
épreuves des Jeux Olympiques 2024 la
première phase concerne les sols une
mise à niveau est prévue entre 50 cm et
1 m 40 de terre seront creusés
surveillance archéologique dans un
deuxième temps les tribunes vont
accueillir 15000 spectateurs chaque jour
et seront installés entre l'hiver et le
printemps au niveau de l'étoile royale à
la fin des JO toute la terre enlevée
pendant les travaux sera restitué au
même endroit le terrain sera remis en
parfait état des octobre 2024 toujours
au chapitre des Jeux Olympiques le
basketteur Victor web benyama originaire
du général-cancourt promet d'être là aux
JO touché par son absence à la Coupe du
Monde il n'y a pas d'autres buts que
l'or annonce le jeune prodige yvelinois
la 51e édition de la corrida de où il
n'aura pas lieu programmé le 17 décembre
la course pédestre est annulée pour des
raisons qualifiées d'incompréhensibles
par l'organisateur du comité des fêtes
pourtant la compétition attire de
nombreux sportifs l'année dernière
environ 2600 personnes étaient présentes
à la course toujours selon le comité la
mairie refuse l'utilisation temporaire
du domaine public l'association food
rock organise une soirée tremplin le 29
septembre à l'estaminet de
Magny-les-Hameaux 5 groupes locaux des
Yvelines et de l'Essonne ont été
sélectionnés au programme rock métal ou
punk un jury et un applaudit maître du
public permettront de départager des
participants le gagnant aura le
privilège d'ouvrir le festival food rock
prévu le samedi 18 novembre